ladies and gentlemen we are going to
watch today it's a short clip that was
sent our way it's only 25 seconds long
um we're going to stretch this out to 30
minutes
it is uh daniel craig's farewell speech
on the last day of filming no time to
die i already got thoughts about no time
to die that i do want to share and then
i'm sure this is going to generate some
more thoughts but obviously we'll
reserve all that commentary after we
check this out let's see what he had to
say i'm guessing he's like finally i'm
done bye never call me never text
and i never want to think of it again
four more knives out sequels coming
[Music]
um and a lot of people here worked on
five
pictures with me and i know
there's a lot of things said about what
i think about these films and all of
those whatever but i've loved
every single second
of these movies and especially this one
because i've got up every morning and
i've had the chance to work
um with you guys and that has been one
of the greatest honors of my life
oh
i mean that speaks volumes
watching him get all choked up getting
emotional just from our opening joke you
know obviously we've heard the things
that people say about how he feels about
these films his experience with spectre
especially talking about that during
interviews and coming off the heels of
that it really seemed like he was over
this and just wanted to let it go
but he didn't strike me as a kind of
actor who would
want to go out on a note that's just
like passive about it he would want this
to end strongly and i think this speech
right here just seeing how emotional
he's getting i imagine he's probably
even more invested in this than he was
inspector
yeah i mean this might be the the
deepest investment we see from him
because this is you know the casino
royale yeah yeah i mean like you know
you got your first one where it's like
you have to make the the stamp and you
have to prove it and especially for him
because everyone's like can't have a
blonde bond who's this guy and he's you
know been so definitive for this
generation he's the kind of actor who
wouldn't also want to leave on just the
public perception of that you know i
think he would want to come back in and
be like no no let's do this right and i
really want to have my full investment
and not be distracted by the anguish of
making one of these i'm sure this speech
was probably a little bit longer started
a tad bit earlier but for him to
specifically say like i know there's a
lot of things said about how i feel
about working on these for him to
communicate that to the crew as he
stated here i've worked with these guys
for some of them here for like five five
films by this point more than letting
the audience know that it's important to
let these guys know it like the people
who he's worked with for so long show
that he has enjoyed his time here like
he knows these people work super hard
too and sacrifice a lot of time and
energy to put these films together as
well so to make that abundantly clear to
them like trust me this experience has
been worth it i have cared this entire
time and i have loved being here with
all of you that's probably the most
important thing to to to communicate
otherwise he might do something in the
future a few years from now then he gets
cancelled because some crew members talk
smack on him you know what i mean right
this is his moment to make himself
cancellation yeah that's what he has to
do right there work up a few tears make
it convincing make sure someone gets on
video i'm really hoping this movie does
well they've reached a point where they
can't push it anymore and it's just cost
them a lot of money from what i've heard
in order for this movie to just even
break even it has to make like
five billion dollars
no but but i would say that you know
that version of the world i'm like
it could be i don't know i forget what
the actual total is but it's like close
to a billion dollars and it's just such
an unfortunate circumstance such an
unfortunate situation because this is
his last outing he's not going to come
back for another one and this movie
unfortunately one of the biggest ones to
suffer the consequences of the pandemic
they've kept pushing the release date so
many times each time it's cost them more
money to do and it's it's reached the
point where they're like look we we just
got to release this no matter what i am
concerned that it's not gonna you know
break even like it should be five
trillion
or whatever crazy well yeah and i mean
you know the theatrical only release
bodes well for it but yeah after so much
time and after so much advertising it's
funny it's like it's definitely i think
more apparent to people as to why it's
been delayed why it's not out yet etc
etc but i mean also all that stretching
over time does take a toll and i can
imagine might diminish business so it
does seem like they're in a rough spot
and i do hope the people show up i mean
you know that could also help too
because it's given us more time to
misbond and crave you know at least that
kind of adventure again we had the the
final trail that came out we didn't
react to it but i did end up watching it
it was interesting watching it because
i'm like there's not a lot of new
footage in his final trailer
i hear the movies like three out almost
three hours long it's supposedly the
longest run time for any james bond film
ever i think it's well earned by this
point especially when they want to do a
solid conclusion on the daniel craig
tale
itself so i'm excited for it and i'm
hoping the excitement for it hasn't been
completely diminished because now that
theaters have been opening back up box
office has been seeing a tick up a
little bit
concerned for the film and the fact of
how it's got so much competition now too
it's like we got so many films stacked
from october to december now that are
all coming out so it just seems like
such a busy time
for it to come out so it's like it
before it had more leeway for a box
office run to be number one for a few
weeks its competition has severely
increased and to be honest with you this
speech is the thing that has made me
care the most about it doing well out of
anything i've seen so far more than any
of the trailers and knowing just some
behind the scenes stuff this red so
sincere to me that i'm like man it's not
just daniel craig who you know put his
heart and soul into it it's all these
people you know family and for a
franchise like this i mean i gotta
imagine that a lot of the same people do
work on these so more so than many
movies it probably does have to be a
tight-knit family unit yeah or they
could just release it simultaneously on
peacock that's the place for it
go to peacock get interrupted by
commercials even if you have the premium
that's that's the idea
well guys no time to die are you going
to watch in the theaters when it comes
out what'd you think of daniel craig's
speech be curious to hear your thoughts
down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and last but not least
there's only one person to shout out for
this one john and i did not
even say who it is but i think when i
count down we're gonna know three two
one
michael lyndon take it away john mchale
i feel for you right now because it's
been such a long wait you've had all
this ti you even got the thing
waiting for james bond it's almost like
you fell victim to some kind of master
plan out of one of these movies but the
wait is soon to be completed mikhail
next
year you will finally have the ultimate
the final daniel craig bond movie and
then begins the horrifying prospect of
thinking who's going to take up the
mantle now lashawna lynch
or lashawna mikhail should throw his hat
in the ring but you know what mikhail
don't even bother
you could be like a great q i bet you've
got some technical know-how but anyway
buddy ellen mirren is playing q helen
mirren oh that's good that's great uh
you know what never mind mikhail you
should be like one of the background
characters all the background players
are neil patrick harris mikhail you
can't be in the movie i'm so sorry i
tried
you